do you think it worked really well I'm a
huge fan of that show all the way up
through the end and a huge fan of the
finale as well which is very spiritual
and it's easy to say now looking back on
you know other things that you've worked
on it's like oh spirituality is a theme
throughout this work but it may have
taken some people off-guard then but I
was curious as you did head into that
that stretch you say you knew kind of
the oceanic that story did you know the
episode would be that would be this kind
of meeting is this kind of purgatory
place well we we knew a bunch of things
one of the things that we knew for a
very long time was that this was that
the series was going to end with Jack's
death that that would be the end of the
you know of his arc as it were to use
screenwriters speak but the symmetry of
starting with his eye opening and ending
with his eye closing felt like really
good to us but then because lost was a
show that really reveled in nonlinear
storytelling and like to jump around a
time we started to become like very
enamored of the idea that although the
final image of the final season would be
Jack's eye closing that we could show
his entire experience post death in some
way Trojan horse inside the show and how
could we hide it how could we how could
we actually give the audience what we
felt like the audience had been
demanding from the pilot which is is
this purgatory are they all dead so when
someone asks you a question
I believe because this is what how it is
with me they're really telling you what
they want you know and so and I felt
like there's a grand tradition from Rod
Serling and Owl Creek and and and $0.06
on up that you know that the that you're
the true growth of the human spirit
actually occurs post death you know that
that's the heaven can wait that's the
scenario where you can you know free of
the mortal coil you can actually take a
long hard look at yourself and and and
figure some stuff out before you
decent transcend one of one of this
before you get sent somewhere and so we
all liked the idea in the Tibetan Book
of the Dead the idea of the Bardo which
was you know and I'm overly simplifying
a vastly complex construct but the idea
of the Bardo is is like it's a place
that you go when you die but you don't
know that you're dead and it's like it
is like Bruce Willis in the sixth sense
spoiler alert like if you if you if you
don't know that about the success but so
he doesn't know that he's dead and so
and the entire purpose of being in the
space is to come to the revelation that
you have died but no one's allowed to
tell you like it's like The Truman Show
in that way so you you can get you can
get pushed along the way or get hints
but no one can tell you and so we were
like oh god that would be a really cool
way thing to do in the final season but
people will know what we're up to unless
we make them think it's something else
is there so can we disguise it as like
as a time travel paradox and so that
that basically led to us backing into
season five so that the incident would
end season five and so when you started
to get presented with you know oceanic
815 flying over a sunken island your
brain would tell you oh this is a
parallel timeline where the where that
where the plane never crashes
so that when we when we finally revealed
and it didn't feel like that was a
finale reveal it felt like once Desmond
started waking up or gaining
consciousness or the Charlie of the
parallel timeline remembered putting his
hands up with like nope not Penny's boat
that the audience would start to get
wise of like how are these characters
remembering events that never happened
to them the only logical answer is that
they're in an afterlife but I know I
didn't see it getting widespread
theoretical attention and so but that's
why season four needed is set up we
time travel into the Dharma times etc
all in service of that grander idea how
we were gonna do all those stories and
the fact that Jack had a son or that Ben
Linus was a substitute teacher like oh
sorry John Locke but if den Linus was a
teacher and John Locke was a substitute
like all of that stuff came in the
organic story breaking process of season
six
but like the big ideas were were
generated in these mini camps that we
would have with the writers in between
seasons primarily between season three
and four and then in the post strike
period between four and five